DUSTIN: Hey, Martin.
What're you doing?
MARTIN: Oh, hi, Dustin.
I like reading articles about
serverless on Hacker News,
but I don't have time to
check the website every day.
I found an API to give
me the latest articles,
and I've heard about
scheduled Cron Jobs,
but I don't know
how to combine them.
DUSTIN: Hmm, you know that
sounds like it might be
a good job for Cloud Scheduler.
MARTIN: And we can use that
with Python in the cloud?
DUSTIN: Yep.
Let me tell you more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Python is often
called a glue language
because it's a powerful
tool for easily combining
multiple different systems.
Part of this is because Python
has great client library
support, which lets you interact
with lots of APIs, products,
and services from the
comfort of Python.
But it doesn't just
end with the cloud.
Python is useful for
combining just about anything
with anything else.
So what are you trying
to glue together, Martin?
MARTIN: Well, I found this
Hacker News API, which
gives me the current top posts.
I wanted it to email
me whenever there's
a new post about
serverless, so I never
miss an interesting article.
DUSTIN: I think we could easily
do this with Cloud Scheduler
and Python.
The first step would be
writing a Python script, which
can get the top stories
from the Hacker News API,
then iterate over every story.
If any of their titles
match serverless,
it'll send you an
email with the links.
We'll use the request library
to make an HTTP request
to the URL for the
API, which happens
to be hosted on Firebase,
a Google Cloud product.
We'll get all the top stories,
iterating over each one.
Then if any of
the stories match,
we'll use some
custom code to send
an email formatted with all
of our serverless stories.
We can put this all in a
single Python function.
We can then deploy this
app to Cloud Functions.
After deploying, we get a
public URL for our function.
MARTIN: Cool.
So whenever I visit
this URL it will
email me any new articles
on the front page?
DUSTIN: Yep.
And the last step is
running it on a schedule.
For this, we use Cloud Scheduler
to create a new job, which
runs once a day.
Cron jobs are scheduled at
recurring intervals specified
using the Unix cron format.
You can define the
schedule so that your job
runs multiple times
a day, or runs
on specific days and months.
We'll schedule our job to
run once a day at midnight.
We'll use the gcloud
scheduler jobs create command
to create a job which calls
our function on the schedule.
We can use gcloud scheduler
jobs list to confirm
that our job was created.
And we can use
gcloud scheduler jobs
run to run it once
regardless of the schedule.
MARTIN: Oh, I got the email.
This is great.
I'll get any serverless
articles delivered
right to my inbox
every day without me
having to do a thing.
Thanks.
DUSTIN: Of course.
Anything else I
can help you with?
MARTIN: Actually, Dustin,
there is one thing.
I'm often late to meetings.
Do you think Cloud Scheduler
in Python can fix that too?
DUSTIN: Hmm.
I don't think I
can help you there.
MARTIN: Oh well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]